hey YouTube averse another episode of
star talk now this star talk Neil
deGrasse Tyson your personal
astrophysicist reporting to you live
from my office in planetarium Chuck nice
that's right sir with that we've got our
cosmic star lock there you go star talk
and then cosmic queries and so what's
today's topic well you know we did
cosmic queries the deep you know we went
deep on some em on some some issues like
you know we got a little more in depth
than we normally do it was multiple
topics we just got deeply just got deep
and now we're going the deep part to us
there were so many questions deep the
sequel to oh look at that
this time it's personal yeah you know
the movie the deep I think had an
astrophysicist in it okay wait now and
it was directed by by Ed Harris the do
yes that is Eddie Harris and so there
were creatures from outer space yeah but
yet they reside in the ocean the ocean
right yeah not bad and it was love of
course at the end that redeemed us as as
a species and caused them to say you
know what we're not gonna destroy you
you know all right cool yeah well this
is of course all I'm just so not gonna
be like that no no by the way probably
they'd be like you do realize love is
nothing but a biological function let
you guys experience in your brains and
we have no idea what it really is and
yep your food your food to us go alright
we always start with the patreon and I
don't always know the answers no you
don't know you don't know questions so
you know yeah I don't know how would you
know if you would know the answers but
you do always have an answer you may not
know the answer but you have an answer
that's for sure you think I don't know
if there was a compliment or an insult I
think that's right neither that was just
know you you normally do have the answer
which I find fascinating you know to be
honest on whatever what else would I be
John Lear
goal of cosmic queries is not to try to
stop you that's not the point
no it's people ask questions you got
questions and I have my the answer this
is John Donohue and he says how is there
anything at all which came first space
or the big bang chicken and egg with the
universe first of all the chicken and
egg has been solved so stop mentioning
chicken and egg real yeah it came first
alright thanks for that ok we done there
where the egg come from from a bird
there was not a chicken oh snap ok that
is just crazy
how's that that's just evolution by
nettle so that's natural selection at
some point the bird that lays the egg
that you're calling a chicken is some
other bird that you're not calling a
chicken right now obviously is probably
several generations took some time
philosophically this is what's happening
but it came first we're done there that
we're done the egg first
there you go alright so now I can tell
you what our thinking is mm-hmm but
there's not some measurement of this to
verify it our thinking that makes that
is that the Big Bang exploded into
existence space matter matter and energy
mm-hmm as well as the hour of time
itself so time space and matter
so to even ask what was around before
the Big Bang hmm we'd be like asking
what is north of the North Pole what is
north the North Pole the question has no
meaning there you go gotcha see just
because you can put nouns and verbs in
the right sequence doesn't mean we'll
have axial meaning don't mean jack okay
so let me get this straight
yeah this singularity happens boom a
second later everything else that is is
inside of that yes so time and space and
all the matter energy matter energy and
matter which we're gonna call the same
thing you know one who turns it to the
other all of that is inside of this
thing that now is in existence yes
dude that's crazy what you just that's
that's our current understanding dude
that's amazing so that would mean that
if space is nothing
oh my head is hurting right now cuz I
was trying to think about if you watch
its base to be nothing yes where there's
no then what would you you know how to
how do you make the nothing because
nothing is space you need a word to
describe where there is no space oh my
god that's crazy
where there is no nothing it's right so
now so so here's what I'm trying to
really have a word from no you don't
right now in fact let's call it
something no we should we should call
that nothing
and we should call what we have
something like it's something that's
nothing yes ooh
chucking Vincent where you go because
thing cuz really nothing is what we're
talking about that's really what we're
talking about there's nothing now we
want to talk about something that has
nothing that should be something Oh
Chuck nice Chuck [ __ ] for the OED
tomorrow morning at the vote hello man
so that so now what I'm trying to
envision is what is around that
singularity and the maybe a heart it's
embedded in a higher dimension right
it's like you're an ant crawling inside
this sheet of paper and that's your
world you have no concept of what's
above or below and you know we do we do
because we're higher because you can
lift the paper up and see underneath I
can see what's wrong and it's still on
the piston inside a dead ant can never
see underneath that page can't see it no
no the N is in the paper right does some
say no it's in the pin in the paper he
can't see what's underneath the correct
that's crazy
that's dimension so that's it so
basically what we're talking about this
nothing is really only resident in a
higher dimension at the time when the
singularity no the higher dimension
people might say it's embedded in this
thing that they call something right
even though if it's nothing to us yeah
Wow
that is great that was dude what's his
name John John thank you for that John
dawning John donohue all right nice that
was excellent
ah I
second I'm second that was really good
man alright alright let's move to the
next one this is from Facebook this is a
Chris
these are patreon no this is Facebook
that was patreon the first one first you
let off with the picture I did because
of course patreon patrons actually
support us financially okay so you know
that's cold that's like say unlike the
rest of y'all no I'm just saying that
they're special because they support us
financially anyone who listens to the
ads that fund this program are also
supporting us if you're listening so the
people I really have a problem with are
the people who don't listen to the ads
especially since you're the voice on a
lot of the I pretty much edition Chuck
thank you so listen to our ads or
support us on patreon and skip the
middleman and give us a direct infusion
of cash I can't go by the Campbell Soup
is that they buy the air knock on the
door the door give mr. Kamath I doubt
all right here we go this is Chris call
Coghlan whoever it
speaking of Campbell's soup yeah okay so
okay for those of you who are not on
video oh yeah this is our sake of this
Wallace's convinced soup oh okay oh
primordial this is primordial soup
that's hilarious
oh there's actually super there yeah
yeah
can a primordial soup open that up and
start your own world not only that what
can I get our could you go put one of
those down what are you pulling down
there you talk just pull the top one
it's fine oh you got another can so now
Campbell's soup Wow Yoda there's a Yoda
soup and it's not baby Oda it's like
growing up yours a grown up yeah yeah
yeah yeah that's pretty cool yeah and
once again mm-hmm it's my office we
should do a thing on my office yes we
should all right delicious I am alright
here we go
this is Chris Coghlan who wants to know
this
I'd love to hear your take of the
multiverse theory do you believe that
every choice ever made by everyone has
resulted in other realities such as a
crossroads example for options left
right straight on and turn around the
theory would have you make all four
choices and only be aware of the one
along a linear timeline which would be
your linear timeline interesting so
let's back that up yeah let's back that
up let's back up citizens packed a lot
of stuff here's where the multiverse
concept comes from okay with when you
take a nice general theory of relativity
the modern theory of gravity correct
gives us our understanding of the
curvature of space and time all right
that's how we get to our understanding
the Big Bang and all this all the modern
cosmology has that as its foundation
right then you have quantum physics okay
which came out interestingly ten years
after the general relativity this is in
the 1920s quantum physics is all about
molecules and atoms and nuclei and
particles okay those two theories do not
play nicely with each other in the
sandbox okay they each work in their own
regimes but you try to bring them
together they are inconsistent with each
other well it's colliding very if it is
yeah figuratively that right all right
so now what happens at the beginning of
the universe when the entire universe
was the size of an atom whose rules are
in charge whoa
you have a shotgun wedding there you go
between quantum physics and general
relativity oh my god and all of us are
pretty sure that quantum physics wins
and in so doing quantum physics where it
pops particles in and out of existence
it could pop universes in and out of
existence of all universes if the
universe is the size of a particle
solutely so the point is let's go back
in time when the whole universe was the
size of a particle what are the rules of
quantum physics telling us they're
telling us that multiple universes could
be popping in and out of existence and
we are just one of them
each one with a slightly different law
physics okay so let's start there so now
there's no limit on how many of these
universes there could be let's say
there's infinite okay if there's an
infinite that means there's every
possible combination of all particles
there ever were right including
combinations of particles with you on
another universe on a podcast where you
have an evil mustache well you already
have a my reality evil goatee okay
here's the nice Chuck right please Dave
and Chuck nice Chuck exactly other
universe and he's still a virgin by the
way so so they it's been hypothesized
that every version of you exists virgin
virgin nice Chuck every version every
virgin so you only happen to be in the
one version that you are in right I so
here's what I would say that people like
thinking about this as a means of
immortality true however why would this
Chuck with all your atoms in this way
have any consciousness overlap with the
Chuck in the other universe none there's
no reason there's no reason for me to
think so because that sucks living his
own best luck with his own best life
right you don't have overlapping
consciousness with your twin no they're
in the same damn universe as you and and
and if they're identical they came from
the exact same single-cell single-cell
right so if you don't share
consciousness right with your twin I'm
not giving reason to think you would
share consciousness with somebody else
who has the same molecular DNA construct
as you but in another year right so
there you have it so yeah I mean that
makes perfect sense
yeah you know that makes perfect sense a
nice question there one more I think
before we break before we break okay
here we go let's go with Claudio Ramirez
Claudio Claudio coming on from Ramirez
Ramirez from Instagram says this if all
matter is spaghettified at the event
horizon of a black hole into what is
light spaghettified whoa smaller pieces
photons or or is it that since the
photon is actually energy it is
zorp by the mass of the black hole so
the light that goes into a black hole
how is that spaghettified as a wave and
a particle at the same time are you
ready oh yeah can you hit but you can't
handle the truth I don't know do you
want the truth I do what the truth you
can't handle the truth alright so first
of all it's not the event horizon where
the action is
right the action is someplace closer to
the center of the black hole where the
tidal forces do rip you apart okay okay
I imagine there could be some black
holes where the tidal forces are strong
enough at the event horizon for this to
happen to you but if you're falling you
will fall through the event horizon you
won't know any difference okay before
during or after all right there'll be a
point before you reach the singularity
where you were ripped to shreds
gotcha okay spaghettified now how about
light light is in a way spaghettified
already it know in a way okay light also
gets spaghettified okay also gets so
let's take a wavelength of light huh
let's call it blue light and it has the
wavelength is big all right good
actually it's a small but just okay
let's be literal here's a wavelength of
microwaves a couple of centimeters
across okay okay you can see that
wavelength all right as this falls into
the black hole right okay if you're
watching that fall into a black hole
right it stretches the wavelength
stretches yes Wow it becomes as we say
redshifted but Shipley means becomes a
bigger a bigger wavelength we said red
because we talked about visible light
shifting to the red side of that
spectrum that's him but I'm using
microwaves which is already redder than
the red but we kept the term it's
getting bigger and it would then become
sort of infinitely red shifted as it
goes down to the to the to the bottom of
the horizon Wow yeah so it really does
actually identify in some sense it the
photon of longer wavelength than the
size of the black hole itself into the
black hole so there's a limit to how big
is the how big is the wavelength it fits
in got you okay the funny thing about
the wavelength of these particles is you
can trap them you could do
interesting things with him by creating
boundaries smaller than the wave right
like your microwave oven which has
little holes this is the size of the
microwave right how big are the holes on
your microwave door I'm just say small
well yeah smaller right smaller than
wave they oops more than wavelength
irregular so yeah so it doesn't come out
they better be it's why you don't fry
eyeball your eyeball look at it right if
they weren't these burritos yeah that's
funny yeah that would be a badly
designed microwave yeah so that's how
you can have a transparent door Michael
to light visible light but it's not
transparent to microwaves
sweet microwave reflect off because it's
smaller so that's what'll happen in a
black hole to light my next break okay
when we come back more cosmic queries
the deep down deep part 2 when we return
you
we're back Startalk cosmic queries the
deep deep oh sure the deep the deep the
deep nice have you as your much gone
deeper to mine yet no you still go
through puberty by saying I am going
through adult puberty so I'm looking
forward to it the deep the deep no you
got that vibrato that scotch vibrato
that's what it is
gods don't drink scotch I love scotch
you're what I drink wine why doesn't do
that all right
back to our questions we have the real
JP from YouTube says this that means
he's famous if he's the real somebody
the real is right yeah how would you
explain what weather was if we were in
fact in a simulation so oh they would
just be simulating the weather yeah no
it'd be the same it's just a simulation
of weather right correct and if they
want to be convincing as simulators they
would simulate everything that you would
otherwise experience that date that they
experienced in their world right so they
would have particles that you know they
wouldn't even have to be actual oxygen
nitrogen until you make the measurement
right right and then B quickly that's
the flag goes up and this is light yeah
that's what it is yeah program in there
the oxygen nitrogen molecules and carbon
dioxide unfortunately and so so they
wouldn't have to have everything be that
but you just program that in here's
something about the air go ahead do you
know the quote from was it Ogden Nash
Ogden Nash said what because either I
Ganesh or George Bernard Shaw okay I
know they're very different writers it's
not same wind is caused
by trees waving their branches oh that's
very I like that yeah in a beautiful
it's a lovely lovely sentiment because
of course we see trees reacting the
manifesto exactly that's I'm sayin so
perhaps that the manifestation when you
turn on the light how do you know it
just didn't suck all the dark out
because I'm not five when I was in
Middle School I had I converted my
bathroom into a dark room a dark room
where you develop yeah it had a little
photography business is you I was in
Middle School
Jesus cran so this is we had an interior
bathroom that didn't have a window so
that wet I can make it completely dark
so I had a little sign I put outside and
it said don't open the door
otherwise the dark will leak out that's
funny I still have that sign - I had a
sign that said don't open the door
unless you want to be horrified well I'm
a teenage boy damn it stuff is going on
in here by the way um what I find really
cool about what you just said is that is
what we're doing we create simulations
right now - tell us about the weather
and what it's going to do Oh interesting
that's exactly what we do
yeah and we do that based on called
climate mom exams and those models are
made at the wood the reason they know
they work is because they're made and
tested on data that's already happened
that's correct so it's so cool like you
you know there you go yeah mm-hmm so all
right nice all right all right you want
evidence when we don't really know
what's going on right when they say 50
percent chance of rain
that is the best evidence when that
models would not worry right does not
work that's smoke okay we got nothing is
really what they say so in the future
you want weather forecasts to be a
hundred percent of this or zero percent
of that right then you know you've got
the right model that's - because you're
really just covering your ass see all
you are freakin a
oh my god yes a little weatherman no 30
time they give a statistic they cover
their a 50% chance of rain that just
means we don't know what's gonna happen
oh my gosh yeah alright Sam champion
we're coming for you all right okay all
right here we go
uh this is Wharram see do who I am Sidhu
from YouTube says why is everything
spiracle and curvy in the universe
spiracle and curvy uh I wrote a whole
essay on this show called on being round
nah he's I think was one of my better
top ten essays on the ground on being
around and so I'm almost not even going
to try to actually I
that essay appears in in my death by
black hole book no really produced there
yes we and might I don't think I put it
in my so it's out there okay so should I
spend time on that here and now or
should you just go by the book no did
why I run black hole barroom if you do
here's your answer
death by black hole Amazon there's a
whole chapter in there on being round on
being on its I'll say in simple terms
it's okay
multiple laws of physics conspire to
make things round when you might want
them some other shape and that goes for
SOPA bottles it go there's no cubic soap
bubbles it goes for forming planets it
goes for forming stars it goes for what
else it goes for beads of water that
ball up on your freshly waxed car after
it rains
absolutely it even goes for it even goes
for vegetables things that have come out
of the ground
like carrots but will carrots there
there Kirby no girl but we talk about
spherical round things like anything
that hangs like form of ice will be will
be around anything the heads from a vine
they're generally round okay so the laws
of physics conspire to make this happen
and that si is an entire exposition on
that and you can just google to you are
such a tease cuz
not tell I think it's I think you can
get the essay without having to buy the
book just google my near the granite ice
the grass just step takes out Mike Tyson
in case he wrote anything that's right
I'm just saying this so so Google
deGrasse and on being round and that
should go straight to it I have a book
called on being on the ground huh it's
where I bite your ear off and I knock
yeah on being on the ground okay anyway
alright there you go um but when I do an
internet search Riley Tyson I have to do
just about I subtract out chicken that's
true and I subtract our boxing it
tightens up the certain that tightens up
the search alright so on being round and
now to give you a more in-depth cuz we
don't have time to go into it yeah it's
it's a lot it's a lot there all right
here we go
Wesley uh uh yes Wesley Tseng wants to
know this hey there my name is Wesley
and I'm from Jersey since we are in the
universe made conscious and the universe
as we know it so far started at the Big
Bang
do you think it is possible that life
was created by the Big Bang itself that
shortly after the Big Bang happened the
cosmos awakened thank you for all of the
knowledge that you have given and that I
have gleaned from Startalk Wow hmm
that's a higher literate thing right
there yes compositionally and everything
exactly he went there
somebody has grammerly somebody speech
good everybody's be good just be good so
I the answer is no right there you go no
this one here's why
right life is made of what we quote
organic ingredients correct so our life
is yes right okay so we've got oxygen
nitrogen carbon these are organic
molecule ament's okay organic chemistry
is all about what those elements do plus
when they attach something else
to it my all life on Earth has those
elements in it exactly those elements
weren't around at the Big Bang
oh they though they were manufactured in
the cores of stars of a kind of star
that happens to then re-release it out
into space so you have to stockpile
generations of these supernova
explosions that have made these elements
and enrich the galaxy you have to
stockpile generations with them so that
a later gas cloud doesn't only have the
hydrogen and helium it was endowed with
it the Big Bang it's got these extra
contaminant enrichments and out of those
enrichments the next generation of star
systems will have the ingredients that
can make planets and people that is
really very life in general I wish that
that was common knowledge that what you
just said right there is so important in
terms of an origin story yes it's so
important origin it's our origin story
the story of life yeah Wow hey man
that's a great question that's why if
you're looking at very very old stars in
a galaxy uh-huh it's pointless to try to
find planets with life on them we think
right that makes sense yeah yeah it was
like yeah it's it's kind of like looking
at cookie dough and thinking that you're
gonna one day just see a cookie no it's
like that dough has to go home it's so
hungry how did you know you weren't from
the freaking Big Bang you know why I bet
that's the best you can do for me it
done so much for the galaxy it expands
the galaxies received ah that no that's
a really great point though that that's
our origin story that's my task five
billion years from now we're even more
generations of stars have sent us could
those star systems have so much organic
material that they'd be teeming with
life like an earth it has only one
Genesis as far as we know maybe they're
planets with multiple Genesis Genesis is
life like they can't it like you just
tripping over life there's so much so
it's material there to make so much
material to make life Wow dude that's
god I wish everybody knew that okay
alright time for one more question we
got time for one more look for this
segment okay okay okay okay all right
here we go here we go here we go here we
go here we go this is from keep looking
up on Instagram mommy's gotta keep
lookin up yeah that's their title right
really keep looking up on Instagram oh
my god what if backwards time travel is
possible but it's only possible at the
same pace as we move forwards and we
will also be forgetting our memories as
it moves so it's kind of a pointless in
the end because you know you just be
reversing the clock okay no one thinks
that when they're thinking of time truck
nobody nobody saying I want to go
backwards in time and then just start
living backwards what the Benjamin
Button version of times round right if
that's not really time travel no it is
that's moving forwards time while your
sorry ass is moving backwards basically
what it is yeah yes Benjamin Button
that's the Benjamin Button time-travel
what a famous author wrote bedroom
button who was I do not know f scott
Fitzgerald that's pretty famous that's
pretty famous yeah in fact he has one of
the most brilliant sentences I've ever
read in my life
alrighty the sense I read that convinced
me I will never be a novelist oh wow cuz
I said I can't write that Ted all right
like damn this guy just did it like okay
it came can I tell you the sentence go
ahead you ready go ahead okay it's from
The Great Gatsby all right okay you
remember it's a big party there's a lot
of like you know sex drugs and
rock'n'roll yeah okay Rowan 21 20s right
oh yeah here it goes in his blue Gardens
men and girls came and went like moths
amid the champagne the whispers and the
stars that's a great line I'm done I
can't that is it is not possible for
that sentence to come out of me it's an
excellent that's that's really well done
god that says so much so much so much
that speaks volumes right like you can
yeah for sure you can hear the
convinced in there yes you can hear the
licentiousness in there you can hear the
the the it's at night and he doesn't
have to tell you it's right exactly
right yeah no that's it okay yeah if
Scott Patrol yeah that's it Chuck we got
to take break okay come back third
segment all right be there star talk
cosmic queries
we're back Startalk cosmic queries yes
the deep these are your deepest
questions that otherwise defied category
I think the right choice just kind of
like yeah we don't care where they come
from as long as they end it dot as long
as they're deep thought all right I
think the ones we've read so far are
exactly really good yeah yeah yeah okay
I've enjoyed it so far you know
nice job people all right here we go
let's uh let's do another patreon patron
all right and this is Jenson smart okay
what what an apropos name for this show
Jensen Jensen Jensen that's a cool name
too
you know how do we know dark energy is
not caused by black holes
I hope Chuck is there on this one I
don't know why he said that I love you
cha that's nice yeah so there we go how
do we know that's not comfortable enough
in his masculinity to say that but I'll
say that we love you chuck oh thanks I
love you too this is weird
[Laughter]
go ahead so here's why all right
black holes are made of ordinary matter
and energy right and dark energy
I think he's being a little swayed by
the word dark mm-hmm
it is some pressure in the vacuum of
space forcing the universe to accelerate
in its expansion and a black hole don't
play that right black hole is the
opposite of them right it wants to pull
things in now let's ask maybe could that
same question be put forth in reference
to dark matter okay
there's dark matter black holes right
not likely
in fact almost certainly not because we
can account for the matter that is
occupied by black holes okay as well as
stars and planets and all the normal
matter we're accustomed to that's made
of the elements you find on a periodic
table dark energy is made of none of
that ooh it behaves completely
differently right not gravitationally
but it does not interact with light it
does not the things that everything else
does to light that dark energy does not
Wow so we don't understand it
interesting so dark energy is truly a
mystery yes sorry yes sorry it's the
longest unsolved problem in modern
astrophysics through this since 1936
right yeah so so van it was originally
called missing matter the missing matter
problem interest you have this gravity
but where's the matter right there's
what would be what would be this
gravitational effect basically what
what's causing yes something's causing
matter Wow
so dark really is just unknown unknown
and it I've made a case I think a strong
case that dark matter should be renamed
dark gravity yes that's what it actually
is right we don't know what it's made of
matter or anything
mmm see now a few calls if you call it
dark gravity now we've actually given it
a thing and well we should call it black
gravity okay because then they will find
out the cops will be on top they will
find out you can't had his black gravity
this is choking on you we don't know
what this black gravity is doing send a
unit organ every which way
yeah universe we got we don't get to the
bottom of this black gravity I'm telling
it right now all right here we go this
is Jonas you got more questions Joe it
Jonesy clipping Steen wants to know this
how can sunlight which transfers heat
Molecular Li spend eight full seconds in
frozen space and still be warm
why is moonlight not the same seeing a
house it is a reflection of sunlight
it's an interesting
question you don't feel warm love the
moon but you'd ever feel the warmth on
the Sun 93 million miles away hmm
interesting
mmm well the moon is not very bright
compared to the Sun that is so true so
because we could look directly at the
moon for as long as your eyes are not
gonna burn hey okay hey nobody should
shield your eyes at the full moon that
is not happening that has never happened
you can stare to moon down let me tell
you how dim the full moon is okay okay
did you see the Eclipse back in 2017 yes
I do Merkers Eclipse mercy if you
eclipse if you didn't see the total
eclipse mm-hmm don't tell me you saw the
Eclipse okay well then I didn't see the
class okay I'm not like you who gets
invited to sorry in Tennessee I was a
secret place it was in Idaho Oh fine
so so here's the thing worse there's why
a partial eclipse is nothing like a
total eclipse okay it's not just a
slightly lesser version of the fault we
ready go ahead when the Sun is 99%
covered by the moon mm-hmm with it's
just a thin little smidgen right the
amount of light that reaches Earth from
that smidgen that little smidgen equals
the light of 10,000 full moons holy crap
so that little sliver of light the
circumference of the moon blocking out
the Sun that a little bit is brighter
than 10,000 full moon correct
Wow all right so just put that in
context damn that's that's all right so
they on a Snapple cap okay so don't so
don't cry about that one
right do you understand yeah we're good
we're good moon it plus the moon
you're not reflective the moon is no so
the moon okay
is only reflecting not much more than
10% of this sunlight that hits it rest
is getting absorbed right so the moon
don't turn to the moon in in moon base
they ain't ain't happen right okay so
it's a B mm-hmm
the photon that's you is a packet of
energy and it doesn't make sense to
think of it as having temperature
it's just energy moving through space
that's you okay
interest then when you absorb it mm-hmm
it vibrates the molecules in that which
absorbed it and that is measured as
temperature so the disruption of your
molecular makeup is really what is the
heat that you're experiencing when the
energy you absorb increases the
vibration radio molecules you experience
that as heat that's it that's correct so
that it's not deep it's not like a bunch
of photons are laying on your body
warming you warm no not warp you're
absorbing them entirely this the
disruption of your molecular disruption
is oh by the way there are photons that
you don't absorb that way
really yes okay now what is that like
ultraviolet photons oh my god it's
really you absorb an ultraviolet photon
you don't feel the heat right what it
does is it breaks apart rather than
making you vibrate more it breaks apart
molecules right in your body which leads
to skin cancer and now you may not use
the word disruption because that's a
disrupts that's it just forgot you see I
was using disruption as just a
disturbance but it's not know the
disruption is ultraviolet you can break
them all if you don't that's why we
don't experience ultraviolet as heat we
experience infrared as he that's right
hit it simply both energy and in fact an
ultraviolet photon has more energy than
an infrared photon right you just don't
receive them the same way oh that's so
good it's only when you absorb it and
increase the vibrations do you then feel
heat I got to tell you something
this show is good we have to enter that
question but go ahead we have to end on
a course we have one more point okay
okay the photon has another view of the
world all right okay do you remember
Einstein the faster you go slower time
ticks for you correct at the speed of
light time stops are you saying photons
don't experience time at all holy crap
so the instant the photon was created in
what we call the photosphere of the Sun
the outer surface okay and then it went
on it's eight minute and 20 seconds
early to earth
if you
the photon you are born and you land on
someone's buttocks in the same in MoMA
in the same moment yes oh oh that's
amazing have no concept of time I saw of
that time passing you were born and
absorbed in the same instant did that
awesome that that's really cool I'm just
saying there you go I'm just saying we
gotta win they ran out of time I know
all right Chuck yeah what's good was
good
Oh what would we call the show again I
don't know Moon Moon Basin don't know
start off starter Macquarie's deep
questions
I'm oppressed we we had a bit of these
yeah man so thanks for joining us Chuck
nice meeting at Chuck nice comic thank
you sir
I've been Neil deGrasse Tyson many of
you are watching this summer listening
in either way you take us we are start
off and I bid you
[Applause]
you